european union finance and economy
ministers will strive this week to forge
a common approach on new mechanisms to
preempt bank crises a key part of the
eu's ambitious banking union
the eco-finn council hopes to agree the
terms to establish a single
decision-making authority the so-called
single resolution mechanism and a single
fund to help banks under pressure
the aim is to help a struggling credit
institution or investment firm recover
from any shock in an orderly manner
preserving its operations and minimizing
the possibility of taxpayer losses
the authority and fund would help banks
to restructure in order to avoid
economic instability that could result
from liquidation
the rules must be agreed on by the
european parliament so eu nations would
like to move the package forward before
the assembly's current legislature ends
in may
the ministers will also seek to reach a
political agreement on rules governing
savings taxation
the aim is to update current legislation
dating from 2005 to take into account
all types of savings income and any
products that generate interest or
similar benefits
the proposal would also oblige
authorities to exchange information so
that interest payments made in one
nation to people from another eu state
are taxed under the laws of their
country of residence
the measures will help fight tax evasion
and tax fraud it's hoped that they can
be adopted by the end of the year